Mack Pete over here I didn't do a face
how's it going brother
my name is fear of hah and what good -
[Music]
yes okay I don't know what happened
there lag look I already got them all
blatant so we have a lot of stuff to
play left and there's a deal see of this
game coming out and I don't want to
spoil anything but there's gonna be a
pity upon that space invaders oh my god
okay what is that I gonna touch this
okay you can have him space invader is
evolving no it's amazing very volatile
scope cap damn it I hate when that
happens
now this is like Pokemon and let's go
chill it I don't I mean no Rafael you're
like my second favorite it's alright I
don't even know if you have a balls AB
some shrooms mag have some [ __ ] [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] isn't he's supposed to do that
somebody references I can't see but I
got unfinished that one what is this
what is this Frankenstein right who are
these two I have a slime ball I'll just
eat it how about charge in my slime
dango well what did I'm sorry if I seem
ignorant sometimes it's difficult
what is oh it's portal it's Paula
[Music]
finally a Pokemon I'll just have your
[ __ ] hat where's Pikachu
it's probably in here I have a cave a
Pokemon [ __ ] yeah what is going on yeah
I literally became a Pokemon and
everyone is super happy is British so
many references freakin Marla comment
come here Brad
I don't probably stick are you serious
why okay so he's only game references
what happening here oh [ __ ] it's getting
Mario hey streams I got my is tripping
balls witness what's going on
what if you play this when you're high
literally don't you don't do drugs kid
that is seriously [ __ ] up okay let's
take the slime and give it to him nice
boobs
that was a hurt what is something for
join boots in this game
alright that's portal hurt there you go
poor Larry there's a cake inside you
that's disturbing
and we explode okay let's take a look
electro house it check it out side up no
thing I decree dude I don't do that
don't do that finish him
oh [ __ ] I'm getting finished O'Malley
what if there was a fatality well I
guess I already got freaked out oh [ __ ]
it what is this who whoa I gotta be a
delusion yeah yeah
I never get here let's give it to him
hey you go brah yeah I don't really get
what what's going on there
parody your couch open it's obvious I
like professor oats beer belly let's
take the poke ball and throw it as beer
belly
take it no I just [ __ ] eat it
go over there that is disturbing it's
[ __ ] okay let me jump in this line can I
do anything here Oh what was that
fish and chains on this fishing rope
solution oh good I knew that is this
[ __ ] clicked on this Wow
I have like pics of these like fix those
became Magikarp apparently what I can't
I can't think what is good I gotta try
that next time I monster appears in them
Nisha [ __ ] splash a [ __ ] on that [ __ ]
okay so we poured on our belly and then
we kick the bomb oh we can't do that
goddamn it poke ball - hey guys alright
that's got a solution
yeah alright
this is click here do anything
nope not supposed to kick it oh this is
last one the bomb oh why did why I don't
care no freaking love this game
god damn it alright let's go to chapter
three health yeah I don't get my ball I
don't know where the quarterback picks
up I never sent I represent under
sentence where is the where is the
unlock map that I unlike Batman
Tobiah I don't know you are a little kid
you gotta have it oh there it is there
it is I'm Sam okay well I got sucked in
holy shame that's gotta be good chapter
three special round any bowmen a
abomination I can't talk that was this
this Simpson yes over you look like a
[ __ ] french fry okay
stop Homer I love your show let me just
sit here just like I'm inside Simpson is
awesome why did I open a window that's
the best I can do what is this aah
demonic boom but do you want it boom but
I don't know I think it looks like a
[ __ ] build up let's give it the
Pumbaa man yeah let's jump let's jump
yeah that's
Spike's eating him inside his [ __ ]
spit him out man poor guy
what is that freaking stone that was the
solution how does the moon should I
don't get this smirk Galman Smurf hello
for hey hey what I became old and son
what is this
Dexter Dexter slob I don't know that
Megan how the hell is a Sangha he I just
remember that Dexter I always mess a lot
more it's awesome alright Barney was
always my favorite
I don't know why I just grabbed this go
Barney Barney you let me down the road
hey dragon ma what is this room tiara I
doc get hybri yes let's see you move it
I knew it
that was not a solution to O'Shea well
you know what I'm gonna pick this car
bed alright I'm a friction that's how
that works
good I am present God similar Scrabble
lady wait it just take the bomb oh you
can't
oh okay why don't we get here
well my well my you do something take
this bond where my I trusted okay
there's gotta be something more with
this [ __ ] I only did that one okay focus
pants no no can't damn it when I say
focus I mean focus all right yeah but
why give it to the girl yeah
gorgeous good Barney
Friday it's gotta do right let's throw
out the window I works that works okay
let's just go straight to him I was
gonna do it all nice chargin whoa nice
nice body feet what who's that
I haven't ridden Dragonball wasn't Aaron
it's written that much I am see let's
just give it a homer no Betty does
something with it or just [ __ ] stairs
at Brown [ __ ] oh good job nine okay
let's see if I can finish this actually
take the present give to him that
doesn't work like this give it it Dexter
it becomes big bad make sense then but I
want to keep saying animation [ __ ]
hey you got a smooth enough solution
nailed it alright
I don't know difficult sometimes you got
to find some weird [ __ ] the Clegg I'd
really don't know what to claim I can
only click this ok let's put this on the
bomb I drink it and become buffest [ __ ]
yeah
badass mech fixer ok real that one let's
do this yeah a little penis going down
there oh man I wish I could do that yes
everyone knows everyone knows Sailor
Moon fatality all right Bryce I also
want to give a little shout out this
game is subscreen steam greenlight which
basically means it can be unseen but
unique in its support from the fans to
get there so do you think they deserve
to be on steam i live in link in
description
I'd like enjoyed that a lot oh it
continues its keiko birthday I'll see
you next episode of Wipeout making yet
the deciding vote lies within me and I
say till they should be Fred leave
Canyon to rot in the way well other
people have swagger that is dirty
sparking to people it's not the people
it's